there's only one Queen same way for me
there's only one king and that means
I am
in like I know you my analogy seemed to
be funny for you but my analogy they fit
into what I am
not funny but I mean this is the Andrew
tight argument isn't it where the wife
is the the kid the head woman she is
like she is my queen she is that she is
the queen absolutely but that doesn't
mean that he won't necessarily on
occasion entertain which is fine but my
my he would never be my man that that's
the only thing
I don't need to give anyone advice
you're what you're saying is like it's
about my pleasure and it's all about me
wait yes you just said it's about
pleasure this is just